the Epic and tragic battle between all
for one and all might just took an even
darker turn and that twist in the end
was heartbreaking I don't think I'm
ready to say goodbye to all might but
with every chapter sir night ey's dark
prophecy comes closer to reality this
was insane and we need to talk about it
you guys know how this works if you
enjoy my MJ content and you want to see
more in the future leave a quick like
and comment right now to help me out
with that YouTube algorithm and if if
you want to help us awaken our Quirk
here on the channel by hitting 2 million
subscribers Please Subscribe right now
every single subscription counts finally
this video will contain mha manga
spoilers so please proceed with caution
you have been warned the last two
chapters had massive all might death
Flags left and right from all might
getting seriously injured but still
pushing himself to keep fighting to
important moments in all might's life
flashing before his eyes as he keeps
talking about how much Faith he has in
the Next Generation the generation that
will take over the fight against the
villains after he is gone and then at
the end of the last chapter even deu and
all might's own vestage inside of one
for all sensed that all might was
fighting and that he was in Danger All
For One keeps getting younger and
younger and the more damage he sustains
from the fight against all might the
faster he is going to age so if all
might keeps up the fight against all for
one not only will he buy time for the
heroes but he could even defeat All For
One all together nevertheless this means
that all might has to keep pushing
himself well past the limits of his body
and because of this there is a very real
possibility that all might will end up
pushing himself too far and that he will
die during this fight the latest chapter
picks up right in the middle of the
battle we see all for one destroying an
entire building but all might is able to
dodge using those dock o tentacles that
he revealed in the previous chapter the
tentacle techniques he uses are named
after class 1a students tentacle and
froppy because they are tentacles that
allow him to move quickly and even stick
to walls so it's kind of like a blend of
tuyu squirk and Shoji squirk as all
might Dodges attack after attack he is
already plotting his next move which
will apparently involve techniques
inspired by Shoto and ojiro he is also
using multiple robotic birds that look
like mini tokoyami to retrieve certain
important items without all for one
noticing these birds are nicknamed anima
a reference to Kota squirk which allows
him to command animals all for one then
shows up right above all might and he
mocks the hero for dodging and running
away after laughing and boasting so much
just a little while ago all for one says
that he knows what all might is trying
to do but it's no use not only will all
for one defeat the hero before he is
rewound out of existence but he will
defeat him with minimal effort basically
all for one is saying that this fight is
hopeless and that no matter how hard all
might tries he won't get even close to
winning all for one then releases a
flurry of black tendrils in the
direction of all might and as the hero
flies up into the air in an attempt to
dodge the tentacles begin forming two
giant faces with teeth these giant faces
look like they're about to devour all
might and honestly this is such a creepy
attack overan has used black tendrils in
his fights many times but this level of
creepiness is just next level all might
manages to dodge the two giant mouths
but just barely and he accuses ol foran
of lying clearly the villain is not just
using minimal effort but Al for one
claims that yeah this is all minimal for
him because this is nowhere close to his
full power the villain laughs and asks
all might what happened to his smile
from earlier he tried to boast about how
strong he was even without a squirk but
in reality he is just a weak old man man
who has to copy the powers of children
in order to survive as all my's
tentacles begin to break as a result of
all for one's attack the villain mocks
all might again saying that now the
entire world will get to witness the
death of the symbol of peace live on the
news to be fair a similar situation had
developed back during the commo incident
and yet all might managed to come out on
top in that situation and all for one
was the one defeated and arrested
however things are definitely different
now all might can no longer use the
Embers of one for all and just in
general the death flags for all might
seem much more blatant this time around
as all might tries to escape the
villains attacks all for one breaks
through the wall next to where all might
is moving and he manages to land a
massive direct hit on all might's armor
this is clearly a serious attack and it
leads to all might once again spitting
blood from his mouth again not a great
sign for our boy all might all might
acknowledges is that the light that once
burned inside him is now gone he no
longer possesses The Embers of one for
all but he declares that he is still not
done yet the hero manages to fire a
cannon attack inspired by Shoto Quirk
right into over one's mouth but the
villain quickly recovers even from such
a Clos range attack all might tells the
villain that he clearly doesn't
understand a thing even if one person's
light goes out another person can
inherit that light and use it to keep
Illuminating the darkness this again is
hugely symbolic and it feels like yet
another moment in which hodik Koshi is
foreshadowing all might's death in a
literal sense the light of one for all
was extinguished with an all might
because he transferred The Quirk to deu
and that same light now shines within
deu but symbolically all might is saying
that he knows that he's probably going
to die here but even if he does the next
generation of Heroes will carry on his
light members of the Next Generation
like deu will become the new symbols of
peace all might might die but his will
and his legacy will live on the chapter
then cuts to a less important fight the
one between ayama and the villain kuna
kuna is one of the tartous prison
escapes and his Quirk allows him to
sprout a bunch of dangerous plants all
over the place as we learned in this
chapter the seeds that he uses to sprout
plants actually use human flesh to grow
ayama is currently strung up in the air
by the villains plants and it doesn't
look too good for the twinkling bro in
this particular moment what's more kuna
has been using fat gum in order to feed
his plants we see that fatgum has lost a
lot of his body fat because it is being
drained by the villain and this is
fueling a bunch of deadly piranha plants
that are threatening to devour all the
heroes in the area one of the piranha
plants actually tears off aama's special
belt which allows him to control his
Quirk the villain mocks ayama for having
a broken power that he isn't even able
to control without the help of a support
item but even though the villain mocks
ayama and calls him a traitor ayama
doesn't let it get to him in fact he is
thankful to kuna for reminding him of
his past mistakes because that just
motivates him to fight harder so that he
can shine as brightly as his friends he
then activates his Quirk despite not
having a safety belt which leads to his
Naval laser Powers shooting out wildly
in all directions the lasers shoot left
and right but none of them actually hit
the villain leading kuna to laugh and
mock ayama even more but then something
that the villain wasn't expecting
happens our girl toru hagakure appears
and she begins refracting the light from
the lasers so that they will change
direction and hit kuna tou has had this
ability to refract light for a long time
and she has been able to redirect aama's
Quirk before but the cool thing about
her doing it now is that the process of
doing it apparently makes her visible
and so we can actually see the invisible
girl in action for once all the tou
Fanboys who have been starving for more
visible tou moments finally catch a
break for like three whole panels this
fight between Aya Man toou and kuna
certainly doesn't feel as important as
the battle between all for one and all
might or the battle between deu and
shigaraki but I am glad that Hoshi
included it and not just for the Toto
Fanboys this is also a very important
moment for aama's character in this
moment he realizes that he can transcend
all his limitations even the limitations
of his so-called broken Power by relying
on the help of his friends he may not be
perfect he may have made mistakes but no
one is perfect that said when the hero
students work together they can achieve
so much more than any of them can on
their own and this fight against kuna is
a perfect example of that with kuna
presumably wrecked the chapter switches
back to All For One versus all might all
might is once again talking about the
new generation the generation that is
still Illuminating the darkness and
allowing him the chance to shine one
last time all might begins to laugh
again and even though he is very clearly
injured like severely injured he still
believes that he will win that the
heroes will win then those robotic bird
drones return and they are carrying
what's left of all might's car Hercules
it's pretty much the only part of the
car that hasn't already been turned into
some sort of weapon against all for one
the birds hold this part of Hercules
above all for one and then a massive
laser beam smashes into the villain
presumably hitting him out of the sky
and throwing him right into the ground
the name of this attack is I can't stop
twinkling and that is how this chapter
ends once again I think this was a great
chap chapter and in general the fight
between all for one and all might has
been excellent on so many levels but the
more this battle progresses and the
closer we get to the climax the more I
think we have to seriously prepare
ourselves mentally because we are likely
going to lose all might in this fight
Hoshi seems to be setting up all might's
final sacrifice he keeps bringing up the
Next Generation he is saying goodbye to
his students by paying tribute to their
attacks and techniques
he continues to push himself too far
against all for one in order to give the
Next Generation a fighting chance and in
the end he probably will die but he will
also manage to either take over for one
down with him or weaken him so much that
even if he reaches deu he won't be able
to do anything about it this fulfills
night ey's prophecy it passes the torch
to the Next Generation and it still
allows all might to live on with indu
through his vestage it all makes sense
but it's still a hard pill to swallow I
also thought it was cool to see aama's
continued Redemption Arc given the fact
that he was the UA traitor his character
needed more Redemption and Hoshi
delivered it was certainly heartwarming
to see that all might clearly forgives
ayama and even paid tribute to ayama by
naming the laser beam attack after him
that said though I know there are a lot
of people out there who think that aama
deserved more punishment and that his
Redemption came way too quickly I mean
it kind of had to happen quickly because
the final war Arc was already starting
and they needed him to play his part but
I definitely understand where this
criticism is coming from the dude was
spying on his classmates for a long time
and he almost got them killed multiple
times what do you guys think will all
for one versus all might end soon or
will it be a while will all might take
all for one down with him or will All
For One reach shigaraki is tagur lowkey
best girl in class 1a let me know down
down below if you're looking for an epic
mha video to watch next don't ignore my
video explaining all of the class 1a
quirks as of the final Arc in the story
link on screen and in the description if
you enjoyed this video and you want to
see more MJ content in the future leave
a quick like right now and if you want
to help us awaken our Quirk here on the
channel by hitting 2 million subscribers
Please Subscribe right now you'll be
doing me a big favor and it's completely
free